hey remember this story about Stanford
swimmer Brock Turner who raped an
unconscious girl on campus and then
received a six-month jail sentence after
being convicted of rape prosecutors
asked for six years in state prison he's
already almost out he's scheduled to be
released Friday from jail in Northern
California and California lawmakers
yesterday passed a new law closing what
they described as a loophole that
allowed this sentence the bill now goes
to Democratic governor jerry brown he
hasn't said he is going to veto it he
hasn't said yet he is going to sign it
and what this basically does and we've
talked about this in other context is
established certain mandatory minimum
sentences for rape convictions I have
mixed feelings about this big picture
but not mixed feelings about the problem
we're having with light sentences on
rape convictions when we talk about
mandatory minimums we often talk about
mandatory minimums for nonviolent drug
offenders and in the context of the war
on drugs mandatory minimums have been a
disaster I mean terrible they are
putting nonviolent drug offenders who
should not even be uh that what they are
doing should not even be criminalized
but that's a different story they're
putting them in prisons because there
are laws that say the judge cannot
execute judicial Bob discretion in many
of these cases the counter point though
is that we've seen many sex offenders
rapists sexual assault is convicted and
given laughably light sentences when
there are no mandatory minimums and then
white-collar crime seems to be in the
middle where we've seen outrageously
long sentences for some white-collar
crimes up to and including life
sentences but then at the same time
other white-collar criminals given very
very light sentences so I'm conflicted
about this Jason because of the toxic
nature in many cases of these mandatory
minimums do you feel that the judge drop
or the jury actually dropped the ball
here and letting this slide though did
the should he he should have been thrown
in jail for more than six months right
it wasn't up to the jury I mean again
the jury
came back with a guilty verdict the
prosecutors requested six years and the
judge using his discretion decided we
are going to go with six months here
there had to be some back to our money
or something just some some correct
politics on it and another thing I heard
I heard the University dropped the ball
here as well in the coming year they're
not allowing any hard alcohol on campus
there they're all mostly excusing this
saying this is an alcohol problem this
is not as angels problem and even drug
saying you know beer is absolutely fine
but the hard alcohol and I get it there
are there are establishments business
establishments that also say hey we we
do beer and wine we don't do hard
alcohol because we find that it just
keeps the crowd more under control I
totally get that but at some point we we
have to talk about the responsibility of
the perpetrator as well and uh starting
to to draw a line between what types of
alcohol are allowed definitely starts to
get into the realm of the sort of a gray
area as to who or what exactly is being
blamed so mandatory minimums
systemically very disturbing to me in
terms of how they're used at the same
time we do need to prevent these violent
sexual offenders from getting six months
and then also being able to get out
early for good behavior tell me your
thoughts on this on which side are you
falling